[Musique]
depuis l'ouverture de la boutique île de
la Réunion au 21 rue du Renard au cœur
de Paris c'est la tradition des ventes
éphémères permettent au régonnais de
métropole de retrouver un peu de goû
pays on a assisté quelques animation de
conseil régional de La Réunion ouis
notamment le dernier c'était là-bas à
côté de champélysée là oui et puis
l'année dernière c'était à Hôtel de
Ville donc
dès ben on essaie en tout cas on essaie
de venir ouis on va goûter ça fait du
bien oui ça fait du bien c'est pas vrai
vous avez pas arrêé de goûter depuis
tout à l'heure est-ce que c'était beau
qu'on a goûé a goûé oui c'était super
beau le chocolat et puis qu'est-ce qu'on
a mangé que de la passion le pour la
SaintValentin exactement voilà c'est ce
qu'on avait compris d'ailleurs ça rend
amoureux le F de la passion je sais pas
si ça rend amoureux mais comme on est on
est touj amoureux alors on pe pass pas
différence au bout de 40 ans ça va en
cette période de Saint-Valentin le thème
choisi par l'équipe de la boutique est
en toute logique le fruit de la passion
l'équipe est mobilisée il n'y a plus
qu'à en profiter on a envie de mettre de
l'événement justement pour attirer des
gens pour donner vie à cette boutique
pour que les gens aient envie de se
sentir aussi comme à la réunion mais en
plein Paris alors il sera un petit peu
plus difficile pour nous de faire des
fruits toute l'année euh dans le sens où
pour pouvoir les stocker ce sera un
petit peu plus délicat donc c'est pour
ça qu'on le fait sous forme de
précommande et sous forme de vente
éphémère donc pour les fêtes de fin
d'année nous avions des fruits de la
passion des mangues des ananas des pâtes
écréoles du poisson frais aussi donc les
gens ont beaucoup apprécié on va
renouveler l'événement en fin d'année et
puis tout au long de l'année aussi on
aura différents fruits différents
légumes notamment aussi d'autres choses
en alimentaire comme les saucisses les
boucanés les bouchons les samoussas tout
pour pour faire plaisir au rayonnés
tuessortir le truc de la
r inéressant
merci truc de la réunion des opérations
commerciales avec des tarifs décidés en
Commission permanente par les élus sont
des coups de pouce pour la production
locale et quand on est à 15000 km de son
île ces opérations ont du sens le fruit
de la patiion plus la Saint-Valentin
hein qui représente le fruit voilà hein
depuis quand est en métropole moi ça
fait depuis 1976 ça fait bientôt 40 ans
ici et voilà je représente cette bouchée
là un goût particulier alors un goût
particulier ça représente ben mon
enfance voilà oui mon enfant c'est que
Ben ce que j'ai grandi avec ça he le
fruit de la passion acheter les fruits
de la passion bien sûr comment vous avez
sui av ben j'ai reçu un petit mail du
conseil général ou voilà puis je suis
venu comme je savais que c'était le
dernier jour et j'ai bravé la pluie pour
venir jusqu'ici mais attends c'est les
produits de chez nous donc alà on fait
un petit effort mais j'habite Paris donc
ça va je suis pas trop loin même si
c'est quelques euros plus cher on les a
sur place non mais c'est super que ce
soit le Rome la confiture piment he ah
c'est agréable c'est agréable
aussi prochaine vente éphémère boucané
et charercuterie de la Réunion la
boutique donne ainsi à Paris et à tous
les Réunionnais expatriés une saveur
locale toute
[Musique]
l'année